my compadre from the NFL media group
Steve Smith here on the show how are you
Steve do you think Adrian Peterson said
I love you to Sean Payton what do you
look you've been on sidelines for
decades what do you think happened in
that exchange Steve I think tamale
probably said something he turned around
and look ap was right there a piece s
and then you know later look back at and
maybe kind of like you know and right
here waiting on you um I just think it
is the emotions of the game ap back home
and then also too they want winning they
weren't being successful so if they had
a good life to do it so well how do
those things happen on the sidelines
where coaches decided it gets in the
game other things happen on the
sidelines that the cameras don't catch
I've been all I've seen and heard your
coaches have gotten to it and almost got
to officially opens the defensive
coaching system things happen on the
sideline that that people always know
and here's other thing guys want to win
so much and you put in all hours in the
game come in sometimes things get
derailed and changes are made there's a
little bit of frustration at
accumulation on the sideline now
obviously you wouldn't know about
frustration and taking on a team that
lets you go no I know cuz you balled out
against the Carolina Panthers when the
Ravens put you on the field against them
what what would happen though if you
were in that game and you weren't
getting the ball Steve would you have
done what Adrian did wasn't like you
know I would say I would always say this
you know if you don't pass me up you
gotta be passing me that for success you
know if you're gonna give the do other
things that are going opposite my way
make sure that you're going in the good
there's a few Pentagon says that the
Belton morning I was kind of running
some routes and they threw the ball to
another guy and I was kind of joking but
I was serious when I told
nutella's like you know if you keep
going and keeping with that guy foolish
one you know you didn't keep getting the
same result this is at all
this is flemmings I'm gonna stress over
here you know really fine dining come my
way
keep gonna get that happy meal over
there you see what's happening and so I
would joke around and stuff like that
but I was dead serious to talk on the
news like all right so in the
competitiveness of it you want the ball
especially it's Monday Night Football
I think it's molar it is more about
getting a better just despite the
opponent at the end of the day we look
at that colony live is going on
they went in the ball they weren't doing
the things that everybody expected you
know as I talked about showcasing his
passion it's kind of the elephant then
you got a TV shows relearning the ball
ap right you know catching a ball or The
Bachelor doing some of the things that
they were doing it's not the identity
that you want to have you lack the
playmakers then I think the New Orleans
Saints and lack Steve Smith my compadre
on the NFL Network you can catch him
every single Sunday morning to start
your game day at 7:00 a.m. Eastern Time
now right here on the Rich Eisen show
and then the on in that game I mean my
gosh the Vikings offense looked like a
juggernaut Steve I mean how much should
we read into week one performances like
say what we saw with Kansas City in New
England or Minnesota last night against
New Orleans just four instances what do
you think I think you read into one one
of the Kansas City Chiefs you see
hundreds of playmakers they have you see
how much they lack athleticism for the
New England Patriots and these nets and
compared to all the guys within a swivel
hips that they had with Kansas City then
when you look at and doing
and st. and you look at the Minnesota
Vikings I look at that team as that
defense stepped up finished exactly
where they finished us at the end of the
season is playing well being a top five
defense and then now giving up the
offense more and more opportunities and
capitalize on them so they're doing good
and then goblin cook is wrong with all
well they pass it all well they ran it
down there well they you know they all
around played a great play priests great
sages of the game and the other things
bit and I think another the Saints are
going to have some trouble against the
New England Patriots because many little
things don't have the clay makers that
the Kansas City Chiefs have Steve Smith
joining me here on the show asked him
the poll question Brockman for for Steve
Smith to chime in on here yes Steve
after one week which team should be most
concerned Giants Patriots Redskins
Seahawks what do you think Steve I think
the Washington Redskins and the Giants
one starting up the joints they had the
star-studded oceans Brenda Marshall
Odell Beckham joining Sterling Sharpe
Evans Eli Manning but they can't get the
but they they don't run the ball very
well their office a lot of struggles and
they just did not look in sync and they
too have offensive minded coach they do
look they look very pedestrian mom as
far as the Washington Redskins there I
watched him in the preseason on one main
concern I had is their offensive line
has a hard time dealing with the PE
stunts and running on and Dilek blitzes
and you know like I did a XO on our show
when they were on a one-yard line and I
won't say his man because I don't want a
man called the descender
like did now block the nose tackle in
front of him and end up in a three-year
loss only when you're on your channel
and a dude lining at the front on the
one line neck ding-ding-ding
block that dude I hear you but I guess
with the Giants though can they can they
talk it up to basically say Odell was
out and that's why we were out of sync
it's week one we're still working on a
few things okay they were they were in
the bottom they were near the bottom of
the of the statistical chart one further
down and rushing they're down conversion
and rushing those two indications tells
me that when they are passing a ball if
they get sacked that they are not able
to get out of the hole because they
don't have they become predictable you
become predictable Kings
T or foon and that's that's what's gonna
continue to happen with them they were
11 and six and barely squeaked in the
playoffs when in the playoffs trying to
throw the ball 28.6% of time out of
those six losses they had that's how
many times they that's the percentage of
times they ran the ball so 71 percent
seventy one point six percent of time in
the throwing a bundle that means you're
predictable and when you're predictable
that's like you know it's like when
you're starting to lose and a third and
fourth quarter and you're running your
two-minute drill it becomes the defense
they salivate because all they do is tee
off they sit in his own coverage and
guys just blitz and can't and then what
is the malfunction I guess is the only
way to put it with the Seahawks offense
that seems to rear its head every year
about and I'm like why don't they run
russell wilson now they're afraid of
getting him hurt because he seems to be
the the the the weapon that they don't
use nearly enough or his legs without it
being him improvising steve because he
thinks that the play is broken down
whereas I really think that Green Bay's
secondary is a lot better than what
people thought and they they're gelling
well and I think they just were playing
better a lot of times what's going on
and weeping on some of these teams it
seems that you question their secondary
have improved dramatically and the teams
have added some weapons and they're
doing some schemes to change up the
things that they didn't do well and it
things that you assume they're gonna be
successful or not the great example is
the Pittsburgh Steelers they like
talking about how rusty every in a
billion he didn't have a huge workload I
think you gotta be like 15 plays that's
not a ribbon and then every time you got
the ball
the linemen were there were people in
the backfield that's not an indication
that's an indication they have a longing
issue and last one for you Steve is I've
got Baker Mayfield coming up in the
middle of this hour I don't know if you
saw on Saturday night you might have
been tucked into bed getting ready for
your early rise on Sunday morning after
beating Ohio State he took the Oklahoma
flag and planted it right in the middle
of the field and then after the game
thought about it yesterday he apologized
for it what do you think of that moment
well yeah he's gonna apologize because
people are gonna laugh so he's also in
the lineage so he there's about his
social media you know people in the bag
who did his anticipate their you know he
bawled on this field and took the crap
and that's what you do in college the
best thing about college you say and not
with the be Steve love you man we'll
chat again soon great job Sunday and
look forward to more of us chat hey hey
appreciate and uh Michael Irvin did not
text me answer I was correct about which
one were you correct on Steve you read a
lot of things and Jinora stinking well
and and there was even a pass
interference on Jenkins I don't even
think he deserved he's kind of hold it
would agree so Mike did not text me okay
that's that's odd Steve cuz normally
he's a very texting type but maybe he
just doesn't like to be wrong this is
fun I should maybe I should have seen
Horn text on the mix everybody that was
when he joined a game day morning dove
in the 9:00 a.m. hour Eastern Time that
was fun
Steve will chat again soon okay
appreciate it all right you got a Steve
Smith age and eighty nine the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stay
across the country and audience if you
liked that video be sure to download our
app and I'll be sure to help the NFL
figure out what it catches